Buckingham Palace has just announced
that Prince Philip is hospitalized this
morning for an infection
Queen Elizabeth carried on with her
commitment at today's State Opening of
Parliament Jonathan Vigliotti is outside
Buckingham Palace in London right now
with the latest Jonathan good morning
good morning Prince Philip was taken to
the hospital late last night Buckingham
palace officials characterizing his
treatment as an infection and a
statement the palace going on to say it
was a precautionary measure and that his
illness is related to a pre-existing
condition Prince Philip just turned 96
two weeks ago he stay at the hospital
means he missed Queen Elizabeth's
appearance at today's State Opening of
Parliament where she laid out the
government agenda for the next two years
the Queen did not reference her
husband's condition but in that speech
he said the government will review the
country's counterterrorism strategy and
made no mention of president Trump's
scheduled state visit she also outlined
plans for the UK's departure from the
European Union we're told the Queen will
be monitoring Prince Philip's health
remotely in May representatives for the
royal family announced the prince would
be stepping down from public events at
that time they said the princes health
was not a factor in that decision
Buckingham Palace does say that the
Prince remains in good spirits but
Charlie at this point it's still unclear
how long he will remain hospitalized for
Jonathan Vigliotti outside Buckingham
Palace Thank You Jonathan